Welcome back to our lecture on list
comprehensions.
What we're going to do
in the second part is talk about
a function called zip that we can
use
to combine two lists into
a single list. Here's the
signature for zip.
Zip has type list of a to
list of b, to list of pairs
of a comma b. Here's an example
of zipping two lists together.
There you can see why this
function is called zip.
It takes two lists and it takes
each value and combines them in a pair.
Zip of a b c, and 1, 2, 3, 4
is a 1, b 2, c 3.
And the zip stops as soon as one of the
lists
is exhausted so in this case you see
there's four elements on the right list
but only three elements on the left list
and the resulting list
has three elements. As I mentioned in
one of the earlier lectures
I think the signature of zip
would be a little bit nicer if it was
not curried. If you would write
pair of list of a, list of b,
to list of pair of a comma b.
But this is just the way
zip is defined in the Haskell standard
library.
Using zip
we can define the following
function
that takes a list and creates pairs of
every adjacent value. Let's
first look at the
example down here, before we look at
the implementation because I think when
you see the example the implementation
is fairly obvious. What we want to do
is given 1 2 3 4 we want to create a
chain
like a sliding window of pairs
1 2, 2 3, 3 4. You see that
the two is chained there.
It's 1 2,
2 3, and then 2 3, 3 4.
How can we do that
and this function here is
I think a beautiful
example of using zip
to do this. What you do
is: I take that list 1 2 3 4
then I take the tail of this list
2 3 4 and then I zip those two together.
Now what we get is since we start
the first list is 1 2 3 4
and the second list is 2 3 4.
Now when we zip it we get 2 3.
Then when we zip the next one we
get.. Sorry we zip that we get 1 2,
the next is 2 3 and the next is 3 4.
If you would draw
the picture, you get the list, you drop
the first element
shift that one up and then you zip the
two and this
is exactly what you get.
Here's another function that
uses the function pairs
to check whether a list is sorted
so what we do is we
take all the adjacent pairs in
the list.
That will give us x comma ys.
And then we check that the first value is
smaller than the second.
A list is sorted if, if we look at
every adjacent pair of elements
the first one is less than the second.
This is a super concise
way to check whether a list is sorted.
Let's just look at some examples.
Is 1 2 3 4 sorted? Yes it is, because
one comma two, one is less that two.
Then the next pair is two comma three.
Two is smaller than three. And the final pair
is three comma four.
Where three is less than four so that list
is sorted.
Is 1 3 2 4 sorted?
No, because the second pair in
pairs of this list is the pair
3 2 and there 3 is
greater than 2 so that will return false.
Using zip
we can also define
the positions of an element in a list.
As I mentioned before lists don't have
any position, unlike array's.
In an array you can
index into the array, but lists you
cannot. With lists you can only access the
elements
from left to right so I can take the
head
and then the head of the tail and the head
of the tail of the tail et cetera.
But sometimes it's convenient to also
have the position
of each element in a list.
This is a fairly common
operation, and the way we do that is
using zip.
What we do is, we take the list xs.
We take the list from zero to n
where n is the length of this list.
But this
really can be the infinite less starting
at zero.
And then we just zip the
the list
with the positions to get
every element here.
If we look at the
positions here,
we get the positions of 0, well
those are these these these and these.
So what we did is we first zipped
every element with its position and then
we filter out only the values
that we were looking for because here
were only
interested in the positions of zero.
This thing goes in two steps, we first
pair every element with its position
and then we filter out only the
values that we were looking for
up there. In Haskell strings are
nothing more than syntactic sugar for
list of characters
which means that you can use
comprehensions
over lists as well. For example here's
the string
abc which
is really nothing more than the list of
characters
a b and c, and hence all operations on
lists
including comprehensions but also map,
filter
foldr, all the list operations that
we'll see
will work over strings.
For example the length of abcd is five.
And why is that? Because that string is
just a list
of five characters, so this uses
the length function over list. We can take
the first three
characters of a list by using
take 3. We get abc.
And we can zip a list, sorry a String,
with a list in this way. For
example if we zip
abc with 1234 we get the list of pairs
with the character a one, character b
two
character c with three. Many
other languages
also have Strings implement
Iterable or Enumerator so you can do
the same thing. But in Haskell really
there is no special type for list, it's
defined as a list of characters and the
only thing is that
there's a special literal syntax just
like
the syntax for lists really, as we have
seen, means one
cons two cons three cons four cons on the
empty list.
Here's an example
where we can count
the number of lower case characters
in a string. What we do is we say:
give me all the characters x in a
string xs,
filter out all the ones that are lower
case
and then compute the length.
For example if we count the number
of lower case characters
in the string Haskell we see that there
are six.
Two four six, and then
the first character is an uppercase
symbol
Alright, hopefully
you've got a little bit of a feeling of
list comprehensions, zip
and the fact that strings are lists
and in the exercises there will be plenty
of opportunity
to practice with that. See you next week.
Bye bye. Happy hacking.